this trial and error approach became the
scientific method the basis of all
modern medicine observe experiment
formulate a hypothesis and then test it
again and again until it's proven false
or true it's a method passed down to us
by the most famous graduate of the s
Columbia
Galen of Pergamon roughly two hundred
years after the birth of Christ
Galen helps lay the origin of modern
medicine Galen was a fight doctor who
actually managed to write down his best
practices and writing down what he knew
to be true
he created a corpus that was not just
useful but was in fact revered for
centuries
well
holiday and then we're professor No
we're gonna land on atomic s Toronto's
on the pollute all of that reform
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they are from stir up the snack world
transporter see they are proprietary
canister tend to talk run can on Genesis
and then a potted a died Qaeda shoe who
follow who still
no but it's grass
Montauk she's got a Cotto darkness to
toe vinegar LF only play
[Applause]
with each procedure Galen was diving
into undiscovered territory
lucky for us he kept detailed notes and
recorded all his successes and his
failures
look at the boy
you know kronor or most Manama cause
artists Marcos de una cita
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
you